hey there ladies and gents welcome to
the shawn method i'm your host chris
waters for something in for sean who is
down south doing video game things for
job joining me is benito gonzalez benito
for chris waters something for chris
waters is benito gonzalez uh and uh
benito's here to help me out because
today we're playing the sims 2.
i've not played the sims 2 very much at
all but you've got some serious sims
experience i have some serious sims 1
experience not so much with sims 2 but
i'm guessing it's not it'd be pretty
comparable it's the sixth we chose the
sims 2 because it's this year's the
10-year anniversary of this game coming
out and uh even though you know they're
i haven't played a lot of the sims at
all but you got it it's undeniable the
influence that the sims have had on pc
gaming and the immense popularity that
those games still have today it's kind
of like the wii sports of pc gaming
right like people who don't play pc
games have played the sims it's just
that juggernaut that is everywhere and
people who you don't expect to have
played a game or like i played the sims
for like 38 hours
uh so today we're going to try to
recreate one of the great dramas of our
time
uh the love triangle and the mushroom
kingdom of course
you know it as bowser kidnapping peach
mario kidnapping her back but really
you know we're gonna recast this as a
suburban drama well they've settled down
right yeah they're they're much older
now you know they're just trying to like
get out of that game get bowser you know
his budget was just drained by all those
airships mario's knees aren't what they
used to be uh so they've moved to the
burbs i've already created the peach
family we'll meet them in a second but
now we're just gonna make uh
bowser is a single dad and he lives with
wendy oh koopa uh his bratty teenage
daughter so we're making her right now
uh she's bald and has only a bow on her
head but
oh there's no bow option so instead
we're going with the red mohawk we don't
have like all the dlc which probably has
a bow in it somewhere we definitely
could have made it happen if we had had
a million hours to devote to it wendy
i'm looking at a picture here she's got
blue eyes
uh
little snake nose with no with just two
slits in front of it but you know that's
a little outside of what the sims can do
so
we'll just go ahead and get through this
quick she does have some pretty puffy
lips
so let's uh
i'm also we're also taking questions in
the chat although
we're not super knowledgeable about this
game well also suggestions suggestions
that would actually be more helpful yeah
and some of your sims stories because
i'm sure you guys have played a fair
amount of the sims yourselves
uh so yeah keep us what would you all
like to see in the sims
like
i have a lot of like crazy stories with
the sims one
like me and my friends used to play this
game like fake multiplayer where what is
fake multiplayer you're kind of
explaining this to me yesterday yeah so
we set up we'd set up like three
computer stations and then we'd rotate
every like hour or something so we'd
like end up in somebody else's
neighborhood every hour
and then you just create stories you
take screenshot pictures of like you
with the other dude's wife or trapping
him in a box
or like filling his house with garbage
filling his house with garbage so that's
that's what that's what we used to do
with the sims and we had a lot a lot a
lot of fun back when you know we were
all unemployed and just playing games
just playing at some of the sims all
right we're gonna make wendy a little
bit of a
bad girl uh she's gonna vex
her daddy dearest quite a lot although
actually can we just go for the straight
up full outfit
what do you think sure
but what is she wearing one of these
guys
she's i mean this is the thing about
making the coupon they literally do not
wear anything except like they
accessorize very well she's got a
necklace but there's no shell there's no
shell there's no shell so instead we're
just gonna have to derive that she is
mischievous uh she's also pretty into
pink but uh pink one
but like pantsuit a pink pantsuit
but like princess peach is super pink so
i think we might just go with like a
little bit more of a punk aesthetic oh
cesaro161 says i'm not the only one who
made dungeons in my basement in this
game and there are neighbors in it am i
no you're not i did that too
no you're not
and that is super fun
sure which one of these looks like a
pink shell
i guess that one
i'm not i'm not feeling the pink for you
wendy as much
oh here we go now that that'll do
uh
underpants for what she does the woohoo
for what she does the woohoo with
i don't know who any
with what whatever random poor
pleasantville people have like the goths
they'll probably be
like the standard family that's in every
neighborhood
all right you get a little teddy bear
pj's
uh
full peach her dad both have the full ph
[ __ ] the peach
wendy swimwear can't overlap this is
princess peach i made her earlier she
chose one of these things all right
let's uh
go for the bikini and if anybody who has
played the sims will know that you can
spend a significant amount of time in
character creation yes i'm trying to
streamline it as much as i can uh yeah
you'll do that and then what's your
personality you're very outgoing
uh
playful
super playful right oh yeah it's like
min max you have to take away points
somewhere she's she's grouchy i mean
she's a koopa
sloppy sure whatever lazy
what is she saying
she's saying singlish man
what's her aspiration
ah romance obviously
there's no screwing with pops that is
so this is this is dad bowser
uh
and this is his daughter wendy this is
the koopa family
and
yeah
congratulations okay yeah we got to make
them related
child to bowser should we make a child
or just a roomy no that would be yeah
unpleasant scenarios that nobody wants
to consider except for the people who do
want to consider it which
all right the koopa family
is moving in around the corner so this
is the mushroom kingdom retirement
from the cage family
yep here we are
let's go check out their house they're
getting settled in okay so day in the
life of the koopa family
i mean someone's got do you think that
like they're the idol rich like bowser
even if he spent all his money on
airships and rebuilding castles he must
have saved a little bit i feel like he
must have had a nest egg put away he
seems like
you know he would have
he's a master administrator you know how
many castles he ran exactly exactly all
right so
what does he want he wants to buy a
stereo get a job an athletic career make
a friend meet someone new
he's afraid of having a bad conversation
with his daughter being rejected for
playing with her it's all wendy-based
and if wendy gets a report card
a bad report card then he's gonna be
okay so what we need to do is make wendy
do the opposite of those things oh do
those things right okay
so wendy
we need you to go goof off and hate your
dad actually let's have a father-son or
a father-daughter interaction
where are they we kind of have to
furnish their house too don't we
all right cool
you want to like get some free money
because bowser should be rich yeah let's
get some free money
in here yeah because who needs a job no
jobs come on
so uh ctrl shift c to open the like the
cheat dialog menu
and then type mother lode
m-o-t-h-e-r-l-o-d-e
yeah 50 grand 50 grand not too shabby
more more more of the money
100 grand that's some good yeah some
good seed money a lot of money
all right uh
let's give them what do we need a couch
catch a bed some entertainment i'm
really not going to put too much thought
into
home decoration
in the bowser family
because
you know i want to get right to the
drama yeah yeah yeah all right these are
couches where's the
to
tvs
build
by furniture yeah store by room
collections yes it's like
well you're in furniture so you've got
to click that and go back ah okay here
we go
yep bowser wants a stereo so he's moving
right am i right
here and the music coming out of this
area is pretty great also the television
sounds are pretty great is this a stereo
no that
computer it's a computer the little
sister it's a quantum computer here we
go
all right let's go upstairs bowser
we get upstairs
come on um
yeah that one yeah boom
all right these are the bedrooms now
we're gonna have to have the stereo
downstairs in the party room this is
where bowser is going to cause some
trouble
yeah let's get some surround sound
you know bowser got that 7.1
ish
whole house is just rigged to blow
where all the traps and
lava pits
look man i told you he left all that
behind yeah that's right that's right
he's done without life that life is over
for him
but
he still wants one thing right he still
wants one thing the one thing he's never
been able to have
a princess of his own princess of his
own
all right cool cool that looks like a
pretty decent uh
couch isn't a terrible place we need a
telephone you need a telephone so you
can call mario over
okay all right
let's find a telephone here we go small
electronics
what is that a fire
detector yeah that's a phone right there
those are phones yeah
there we go
now we're talking
uh
do some beds is that a thing i mean how
are you gonna cause trouble if you don't
have a bed to cause trouble
and what's the screenshot button because
this game is all about creating stories
through screenshots
surfaces comfort i don't think the music
changes walking in the park walk in the
park when things go downhill i don't
think
i don't think the music's dynamic like
that but when you turn on like the radio
you'll hear like different radio
stations or if you play the guitar or
the piano you can hear him get better
oh he won't be terrible the whole time
he'll be terrible right in the beginning
he'd be like really terrible
all right we got two bedrooms
set up
uh should we put anything weird in there
fire alarms need a fire alarm because
your house is gonna burn down
really yeah man i need some i need some
lighting fixtures
oh yeah lights are pretty important too
yeah
definitely getting some lamps up in here
oh this place is hella habitated
in inhabited
habitation habitation
thank you careful shark one f2 is
screenshot
all right
this one has to go over bowser's bed
because he is prone to
uh
flame sneezing
yeah i put one in the kitchen
right over the stove that's not gonna
cause any problems when you're cooking
all right how are we feeling about this
all right i think i think that's all the
essentials right there okay let's start
living a life let's resume
living
start acting
burglar oh she's afraid of burglars
getting rejected for her first kiss
being rejected for being a flirt so i
think uh i think wendy she likes to piss
off dad right she does so she wants to
call mario over
wendy's making a bid for mario oh man
love triangle here
what's all those
what are those black things i guess
that's a graphical glitch we didn't
patch this
there when he goes upstairs he's fine
what she's thinking about her dad
what are you thinking about here wendy
fire alarm fire alarm fire just
observing things in your in your life
are you turning on the radio it's the
music there's the oh yeah
what does wendy like to listen to
father-daughter dance party
what is that already happening
it's already happening they're getting
grouchy with each other yeah this is
working out all right
wait oh but they're dancing now they're
they've made up
nope that's a weird
dance pose come on
i'm trying to get the f2
going oh cause oh so you like wait
i pressed f2 to do the screenshot oh
maybe that was the wrong button it like
paused f12 and he mistyped
well they're getting along
can't have that hmm
yeah so like if you're on her you can
click on bowser to make her interact
with him in different ways
hold it down and then you say like i
want to do this stuff
and what's the stuff bowser's scared of
so let's yeah let's look into his fear
his fears are being rejected
having a bad conversation with wendy
be booed wendy gets a d reporter okay so
we're never sending wendy to school okay
how do we keep her from going to school
because the bus shows up you just don't
send her to the bus okay
unless she goes by herself but if she
goes by herself you just take control
and say no no lady uh i'm gonna brag
about some [ __ ] to my dad
he likes it you need to complain or like
talk some [ __ ] or get a boy over
that dad doesn't like
maybe they just keep bragging to each
other about stuff
dad's gonna gossip
you guys are dancing
all weird how do we alright let's get oh
wait no i don't want you to
yeah sure you need to stop having a nice
conversation with your daughter you're
gonna run away yeah so you can see up
top left you can see the queue of what's
happening you can always just click on
those to cancel them out oh like stuff
that
see like right there she's activating
the stereo
no bowser run away
he likes the music
you need to sew discord in this family
oh yeah go okay so he can go turn it off
okay so whenever you see somebody
walking outside right go talk to them
and they'll come in here go get her go
get her
dino
run here
easy easy easy easy take it take it easy
bowser bowser cool
he wants to talk to you she wants you
dina
what's up dina caliente oh hello
except you know who i really want bowser
to talk to
is princess peach should we go check in
on them yeah sure let's check on in on
the brothers family
oh you just got some semolians
gave him money
no not
no i misspoke i don't know what a
simoleon is
simoleon is money chris they're having a
good conversation but i can irritate her
no i want to entertain with a joke
i wendy you to go be annoying as hell
here madness wants to capture the
mailman that's a good idea
capture the mailman yeah should we build
like a little prison
you usually want to get them if you put
them on your land you can build like
walls around them and put windows or
something and have a little zoo okay
she's gonna go brag to this lady about
it so how do we all right we're gonna
come back and build a prison here in a
second but i think we should
uh
uh oh yeah the daughter's pissing her
off
no you
you stop messing you our class you
you're not good enough for my dad no our
class you get out of here you drop it
you like each other books damn it books
no stop talking about books
she doesn't like books all right now
we're talking yeah bowser tina kayanta
don't read
all right
that's a pretty good start bowser what
are you doing you being weird oh she's
coming in oh she's coming it's a trapper
in a cage benito
oh she's about to sit on the couch it's
all right she has to get up from the
couch sometime yeah but then but then
you're going to trap your little girl in
the cat in there too
i want to i want to pause it when she's
yeah she's isolated somewhere all right
fine
fine dina
wendy
no you're making her leave the house
wait
bowser shoo ask her to stay asked to
join
okay that should work oh no you can clap
her outside yeah okay do it now i think
the building
the building tool the one underneath the
no the other one on the left yeah all
right yeah here we go now you want a
wall and then now you can build the wall
around it
let's get some exterior walls going
all right
most curious
i was curious indeed
uh we need an addition to our house
room tool
describe to me what i should do room
tool
click and drag automatically to build a
rectangular room
right off of our
no
no
work
it's not it's not working oh
wait is that peach oh that is fish isn't
it i think that's princess peach
all right no go get dina
dina you're gonna be the test case for
trapping
like how come the walls don't work i
don't know
does that do i have to get a building
permit
is my building not up to code
night time the perfect time for building
walls around innocent neighbors does
does it have to be going
no i have no it has to be in the build
notes yeah
all right i might have
okay
build
nart
i'm vexed i'm sorely vexed
yeah click and drag to build walls on
either terrain
or foundations control click and glad to
shift click and drag to create a
rectangle
why are we not allowed to build
is this is there a building phase that
we have to enter is there no this is it
like the building tool
um build tools i tried building
not even letting us put doors in
hmm this is strange why don't we
go to another house real quick and see
if this is like a
thing what's yeah what's that button
above yeah yeah
oh yeah that's this that's the cut away
the walls let's show you the walls
i want a window in this wall what the
hey
anyone in the chat shining any shedding
any light on our current building
conundrum
control click removes a window at the
second floor
what
multi-story well these are multi-story
windows so
it's still like what if it was just one
of these single windows it should be
showing up right it should just pop
popping up like you were dropping the
furniture
dang it mario i want a new stone pathway
i can't build crap
nah
yeah that's
all right that's really screwed up time
to focus on romancing peach
are you like not allowed to do that in
sims 2 when you have people over no one
in my house that would be stupid there's
no they left oh that's right dean is
gone that's right what the hell
all right where
are these clowns at
bowser
go talk to princess
run over talk to her
greet princess peach what's up peach
nice to meet you stop it oh
get out of here darren
actually you know what you should watch
you should go ahead and talk to darren
oh it's working out swimmingly for that
yeah
go you go drink that agree darren
well cool it oh it's not good they're
talking appreciate appreciate her
admire her no
get back here kind of have a party going
on right here seriously you need to
uh talk
uh just chat yeah
don't don't be terrible meanwhile you
need to you need to flirt with darren
come on be an irritating
daughter
by yooku
says hello from turkey what's up turkey
a graphics guy is turkish he just came
from turkey
oh they're talking about i say hi bowser
is bowser loves makeup and he's talking
about jewelry oh my goodness she just
said pearl necklace that's what he said
yes i would love a pearl necklace
hats what about hats
oh my
oh he's thinking about peach too homie
over here thinking about peach listen
wendy get up
he's chilling he just talked he just
complimented her on her dress
i think it's time to kick it up a notch
oh yes elite pirate says you can't build
with guess over that sucks sims 2.
seems wonderful
technically they were over because they
had like they were all descending in a
cloud on my house so i guess you can't
do the man in a box anymore well let's
see
is she is she a guest over let's see if
i can okay now i guess how you have to
do the man in the box now
is you have to make a room
with a halt with a with an entrance way
and then
put a piece of furniture in front of it
when you get them inside
oh okay i think that'll work all right
all right let's give this a shot so wait
i can't build while there she can she's
almost left people she's over right
we're still throwing serious game at
princess peach yeah you need to get the
oh oh wow he's not into it anymore
bowser damn not into it anymore uh
apologize
no not sir don't say sorry
you're not an astronaut
you are not an astronaut well you don't
restaurant either teddy bears
damn it wendy
listen i appreciate you princess just
because you're not an astronaut what is
she dreaming about the piano back there
fine great
uh maybe you should entertain her with a
joke
bowser was always a good joke sir
like with his eye test jokes
goopy this dude's name is goopy yes
go talk to goopy gills carbo will you
get off your ass get off my lawn wendy
what are you doing stop watching clouds
you are useless
oh thank you
greet goopy
nova night there we go we have not set
up the death pool tell us how to set up
a death pool that sounds great
come on
talk to don't
talk to goopy
go chat with goopy
yeah bowser this seems to be going well
they're talking about happiness
uh
do you think it could give a hug now or
is that too forward
i bet you she'll say no like what's your
friendship status without i you have to
see what all those like all the numbers
let's see how the friendly hug move goes
bowser he's just trying to make up no
too forward she still remembers all
those long years spent being abducted
quick tell jokes
that looks like you're just laughing at
her
damn it i think i might have told her to
tell a joke to him
all right listen i appreciate you i am
so admiring at you
okay
161 has a great idea of building a pool
then when people jump in the pool you
remove any way to get out of the pool
yes okay that was that was wait no we've
switched oh god
go talk to goopy
i want you you gotta get rid of these
people so we can alright filled out
death traps cool all right never mind
say goodbye goopy
princess
uh wait i'm just gonna throw a flirt at
her real quick before she leaves she's
going into my house i mean this is gonna
work all right goopy's gone
listen i'm working the princess game
wendy go upstairs
go to your room
papa's having a discussion
with a lady
some dude is doing calisthenics in our
front yard but that doesn't matter
because bowser and the princess are
getting down in the living room oh yeah
working out for bowser
this is the life he always dreamed of
it's all he really ever wanted bonito
yeah but mario just wouldn't let it
happen wendy
no meddling
go upstairs
you go to your room young lady
daddy is having a guest over
and he is walking in on her in the
bathroom they are hanging out together
in the bathroom wow
this is going better than i ever could
have hoped but you know
okay okay okay put something in front of
the bathroom door
you can even just move that
move even move the couch
see if that works
all right
oh it doesn't let you do it anymore
wow where did the couch
go originally i can't even put it back
yep that's a good place for a couch
all right listen couch you need to
become unmoored again how did i do that
all right okay so hold on let me just
see if i can get an easy chair in here
or a table
yeah
nope
this is weird
i feel weird about it
but at the same time i feel good about
it
all right
what would be a super yes put the
kitchen table there
and then oh
i think you have to like
flip it around see those where the
arrows point that's like the front of it
uh okay i've bought a kitchen table so
you can put just put another table there
and then you could build a little thing
around it
like up one up one block there she
shouldn't be able to get out of there
all right we'll see
but i feel like there's a tiny
area that she can squeeze yeah but
it's just the squares those are like the
paths so there are there's no square
between there i don't think she can get
out all right let's see
let's see if we've managed to
successfully ensnare the princess
how
unladylike she flushed after she was
done
uh oh oh yeah you're not going anywhere
princess successfully abducted
cool i mean it's hard now because they
can't like well you can change that
table to a one square yeah real up and
close and personal
uh just forking her across the table
oh she's pissed because she can't move
all right meanwhile
i think that's that's pretty solid work
so what what do we do now so now let's
see what mario's state of meanwhile
tragedy strikes at the mario household
all right
let's go back to the neighborhood
i can't quite see the neighborhood so
production back there sent me this uh
website
of how to kill yourselves
how to kill our sibs so like all the
different ways you can kill your sims in
this game
but before we do that
a message from our sponsor
we'll be back
with murder
we're back and we're plotting
some serious calamity in the mario
the mushroom kingdom situation here all
right we have moved over to the mario
household where we find this cookie cut
our house with no furniture mario's
house is yet to be furnished but that's
okay
and mario
i think she's nowhere to be found peach
is nowhere to be found she she's just
out for one of her walks she takes them
uh
pretty often oh no wait she's here damn
it how is she here how did she get it
she's here and she's with the baby all
right so this is peach and baby mario
let's get a look at these two each got
out man they took out all the fun stuff
so you have to be super tricksy about
how you kill people now all right here's
peach and baby mario
uh they are a beautiful and happy family
together
this thousand-yard stare in her eyes is
because she wonders how life might have
been
if she didn't get rescued all those
times secretly she doesn't even know it
herself
uh all right but we need to make some we
need to make some dangerous situations
here yes so as it stands no one knows
how to cook right
and if you make someone who doesn't know
how to cook
cook something they tend to burn down
the house it's going to be a bad scene
all right so we gotta go down one more
floor
how many freaking floors does this the
mansion have
there's also an elevator crash that you
can make happen
uh is this the worst stove i think it is
the worst stove and just don't buy a
fire alarm or else the fire department
will come
that's those four hundred
or should i just put a grill inside
indoor it's an open charcoal grill
indoor taco what's wrong with that
all right uh
what else do we have
what yeah
you get a lot of fluffy fluffy rugs
because they like to burn
fluffy rugs are pretty flammable let's
find some rugs
comfort that sounds like a rug is a
comfortable thing no
uh surfaces there we go i think you have
to go to oh is that like a miscellaneous
is that a build tool it could be it's
flooring okay there's a carpet carpet
two dollar carpet no we want the super
shoe we need the super shag carpet uh
these tiles are terrible
how can you tell if it's shag carpeting
or not i think in the description
macrame but there's also like
rugs not carpet
brick
all right so that because this is in the
floor this is like wall to wall yeah if
you go to go back to the furnitures
and like the miscellaneous three dots
i think it's a decoration decorative
we need we need some curtains yeah we
need some long curtains over these
windows
in the kitchen
yep put them outside
nope
there we go
how regal beautiful
all right what else do we need besides
some carpeting
flammable wood furniture need a
fireplace a fireplace would be
fiery fiery
can we just see if i were the fireplaces
was these miscellaneous fireplaces
those bars or fireplaces
these are bars
they could use one of those
oh these guys don't have money boy could
they
time for them to hit the mother lode
bam
okay so if we're going to successfully
trap somebody
we need to get them in the house and
then not leave that house or else
apparently they port they teleport back
out yes so we need to get everyone in
this house before we try to set it on
fire
is that what you're telling me yes
and then we need to open it up so that
only some of them escape and live to be
haunted we could also try tragedy we
could also try the death pool
how about like
some comforters
is this going to be a good kitchen
situation
that seems safe just relax
everybody go have a pow wow in the
kitchen
ah see this too square that's perfect
for a little cage
can i demolish a wall
i think you put a door there and then
take out the door later
i don't know if that works anymore
though
you know
it's almost like ea decided with the
sims 2 that they didn't want the leading
story about their game to be how
maniacal everyone can be and then
creating horrible death scenarios it's
one of those games that you get what you
put in
you can put a door there
no there's no doors and what i don't
know
how can that shouldn't that work listen
man
science science
all right can we get this in motion how
do i make one of you hungry
just go about living your dumb life just
make it super fast and they'll get
hungry eventually
all right how do i amp up the speed uh
see that play button down there
underneath the date yeah
what are you doing where are you guys at
all you're smooching talking about
babies meeting some neighbors reading
the paper reading the paper oh you're
just hanging out hanging out front with
the baby in the garbage can
mario why are you like
playing with the baby by the garbage
living room is in the kitchen
oh visitors
peoples
all right when are you gonna need food
what is this litter
actually you can just make them start
cooking okay yeah on the stove click on
the stove
all right mario
no actions we need to buy food or some
crap oh we don't have a fridge
boom here's a refrigerator
yeah placed awkwardly in your dumb
living room
where your seats probably should be
this is a real cool type house
it's a super mario brothers house have
lunch where are all the tubes tv dinner
sure
get out the way
oops
what is that who put a grill who put a
giant couch in front of the door
i do declare
i see
i don't know what this i don't know
what's going to happen
he's mad because he can't because she's
in the way oh there she's going to cook
come on mario she's getting a drink oh
there's a back door bottle
stop the back door babies
over here
behind the couches
you can also use one square seats
listen what are we poor here
all right i'll at least make it face a
good direction i'm not a monster okay
yes i am
stop standing in your big black square
of oblivion and make some freaking food
why is tv dinner the only option
because you're not good at cooking how
do i get good at cooking gotta read
books
books what i thought this was a video
game man
they're not real books
all right good
you don't actually have to read them you
know what else i think would be good
plants
hanging plants above the stove
yeah
let's make it get a bunch of
plants in here
stove
oh yeah look at that it's a nice little
jungle picture of another woman
on your wall
behind the fern behind the fern above
the stove excellent
excellent
mario your decoration is terrible oh
yeah she's hungry for chair
all right you need to make her chair
turns for a chair
there we go oh look at the picture he's
pining over his he's pining over who's
this pauline yeah why are you looking at
picture pauline again i told you not to
put that in the kitchen mommy
each baby mario to
whole [ __ ] sure hold baby mario and
then
make dinner
mac and cheese mac and cheese
what is with these weird
oh gosh it's so weird no i don't want it
i don't want to order you around just
make some mac and dang cheese
oh i was complaining about beds
oh she's gotta chop up the mac and
cheese real quick yeah
make that mac
put it in a bowl
mario what are you doing he's hungry too
he doesn't like he's finally making his
tv dinner screw your mac and cheese i
want tv dinner yes use the oven
now run away little microwave nope run
it oh there you go there you go there we
go all right
there's no way out where's the baby the
baby's in the bathroom
oh no i can't build any furniture while
everything's on fire oh [ __ ] is it baby
gonna get orphaned we gotta save the
baby
mario
how do i save the baby baby go to the
door crawl out the door baby move baby
save yourself baby oh you're sleeping
can't you tell there's a fire
mario's freaking out he can't he's gotta
sit on the couch oh god which way
there's no way out it's horrible my
pauline picture no no it's all going bad
the baby's asleep wake your ass up baby
oh don't you know there's a horrible
fire
all right you should take a nap real
quick
no go have a seat sit in the fire just
just have a seat
oh it's spreading no the fire's
spreading no we don't want to cancel
oh baby got up baby got up baby where
are you baby baby you need to get you
need to go out the door save yourself
baby
baby sleepy
oh i'm so tired i can't save my own life
stupid baby
babies oh the stove is gone survive the
fire has spread
to the couches
the pauline picture is gone
mario continuing to just stand and dance
in front of the fires hopelessly
oh gosh
i think they're fire worshipers he's
like oh there's no mushrooms i'm
literally powerless without
mushrooms meanwhile this mac and cheese
is just going cold oh i guess
now yeah
baby go outside
save yourself
i know you're not going to be able to
open the door oh baby's all stinking the
baby has carbon monoxide poisoning and
has passed out
by the bat he's farting constantly and
he's just ripping little baby ass over
here
baby fart all day he's filling the
apartment with flammable baby methane
farts okay mario's about to go down
mario it's coming i think mario's about
to go down he's not looking good for
mario
he has lost
oh yeah he's he's about soon we're gonna
see him revert into his teenage phase as
we all know mario's died slowly and then
soon he will become a baby you need to
run over here very uh benjamin button
yep and he's
oh gosh oh the horror
mario peach like doesn't want to get out
of the way
as her
longtime savior mario
burns in the flames well you know she's
got an ulterior motive right that's true
i mean she has another level like part
of me is like dang i need to save you
but another part of me is like
maybe baby mario and i could make a life
together with bowser and then his
daughter could babysit all the time and
then we could go out to the bars and
stuff
and bowser will finally have his how
many burned items is mario gonna oh
there he is mario has turned into a
bottle of ashes oh gosh oh death has
come death has come from mario and peach
is also on fire how do we get peach not
on fire we need to save immediately
extinguish
there's no fire extinguisher what
happens if you go to the neighborhood
now we might have an orphan baby on our
hands oh no we're definitely going to
have an orphan baby
let's see if death saves the baby oh
maybe still alive the baby is fine
are you not gonna extinguish yourself
i've told you three times i'm not gonna
tell you again because she has to like
get on fire be on fire move and then
extinguish yourself
all right let's just let's just
eliminate the being on fire parts look
use this rotten baby bottle and just
squeeze it all over yourself you're also
smelly you're smelly and dying oh
there's a guy
okay so we have uh we have a an orphan
situation
and there's baby mario passed out in a
cloud of his own stink
so desperately hungry
really i don't think he is cognizant of
the tragedy that has just altered the
course of his life forever he doesn't
care he's sleep and stinky
oh death will take care of him
he's calling a friend right now on his
cell phone death is like you got bowser
you're not gonna believe this man you
gotta say this bowser bowser i know you
remember you told me to call you if
anything happened to the mario family
well i got some good news and some bad
news mario's dead
oh it's hey bonito it's not a good idea
baby no that's probably not got some
good news bad news mario's dead but uh
but so is peach princess is also dead so
so now you've got a little bit there's
really just this baby so if you want to
like revenge raise the baby
uh
that's cool you can do that is this
child services
is it it is i think it is
child services is coming to take baby
mario away
i just phases right through the wall
where were you when it was on fire
child services lady
this
who how who who is child services lady
in the mushroom kingdom cannon oh that's
a good question she just came to abduct
the baby and phase through a wall this
is some sort of evil sorceress who's the
evil sorceress of the mushroom kingdom
toadette oh you know those those those
witches
what who are they i don't know what
they're called though
come in on brooms and [ __ ] yeah but
aren't they just in zelda oh are they
zelda oh you're right i'm thinking of a
different mario kart death is always
tragic especially when its effects
directly touch ones i'm young as ones as
these
more even tragic is i think tax
collection agencies are pricing this up
for sale in order to care
for the cost of orphan care going
forward oh man they just had a weight
involved growing up mario's been
collecting coins his whole life yep and
all for what
so that baby mario one day could be
whisked away from the scene
let's let's just take a moment of
silence and observe the charred remains
oh there's the urn
oh is that mario that's mario
oh there
are no actions available bonito and
isn't that one of the most touching
eulogies you've ever heard
i'd like to say a few words oh there's
peach i'd like to say a few words over
peach uh you know and whenever we reach
this point in our lives as we all must
we confront the truth
there are no actions available
meanwhile over in the
household oh gosh paul has settled over
this barely furnished house they were
just starting their lives together
they didn't even have a bed yet terrible
interior decorators
barely able to even feed themselves now
just two urns
a rotting tub of mac and cheese
and a rotting baby formula the only
evidence
that a baby once crawled and pooped
himself in these hallways
that in the smell the head and the smell
oh god the smell this is probably a tear
down
all right
i want to go to the neighborhood now
and let's go see how other nate let's go
inquire with the other neighbors and see
how they're doing with the recent
tragedy of their new neighbors because
they all must be stricken right yeah a
horrible house fire the baby left alone
i can only assume that the koopa family
is in mourning so let's go see
how wendy koopa and bowser koopa are
dealing with the recent tragedy
princesses
yeah gone music is still playing some
salsa music and they're dancing he's
still dancing over at the coop they are
literally dancing over the death of
mario and peach
and the orphaning of baby mario
oh
you can't make this stuff up folks
they're becoming a stronger family
oh no
it's true she's just gonna watch some tv
she's gonna put on mtvt mtv2 now
oh they're both just gonna friggin chill
out
like it's over like the threat to our
life
is over
she's she's happy because now her dad
won't be leaving her for you know
another we'll be starting another family
you know think about it like how many
castles of bowsers did mario destroy in
his lifetime so many so many castles
he's got his comeuppance and he has a
cheap recliner to enjoy it in now
oh they're dancing
they love it
i do love it oh they're living high on
the hog you want a refrigerator sure
let's buy you a refrigerator
because then you know then we can burn
your house down because then we can put
your house down and the karmic uh come
up it's will be yours i can't buy
appliances for some reason really
i don't
appliances is grayed out
what the hell
the game is weird fine why is it because
you're talking about
your crappy recliner that you now have
all you do is dance and whisper oh
you're talking about
pete what are you talking about is that
peach she's dead
she's dead yeah i know
that just brought us closer together
what does he want no it's a meat foods
he wants hungry all this
all this celebrating has made me hungry
yes let's hug it out oh yeah i think
that recliner gets in the way of them
getting to them to a fancy dinner no
they can get past that recliner can they
i don't know sit in this recliner
i do want to nuke one of these tables
though i don't understand why you can't
build a fridge right now let's go away
all right
look there's all this space in the
kitchen i can put the fridge next to the
stairway everywhere you can put the
first all right wendy koopa popping a
squat we're not gonna watch that what
are we we're not we're not sickos people
why can't i buy a refrigerator
he wants one i want to give him one
oh bowser wow sucks girl made a really
interesting observation oh that if you
bought the sims 3 with all the dlc it
would cost you 430 what the hell
430 dollars
wow that's ridiculous
that's
wow and that's like you know all the
expansions and such i guess there's a
butt loaded dlc for that game jeez
that's intense
all right look
now that's
applying maybe they're like yo you are
not allowed to cook anymore
you killed two people i had a baby taken
away
but look wendy needs food too
these people are just gonna die from
food you can call pizza
oh yeah yeah the phone all right wendy
fine bowser
call in delivery
wendy i want you to go at the same time
to try to call something
we're going to call people for a party
invite headmaster
we're throwing a party
uh it's it's awake it's not going to be
festive at all there's definitely not
going to be cuban
salsa music playing but there will be
pizza there will be pizza
there will be sadness everyone is
wearing these uh yup i would like to
order pizza
everyone he's she's getting mad at dad
for being in the way
these are these are black squares of
mourning benito not black squares of
improperly patched video game
it's meant for
all right stop being cranky go throw a
party we need to end we need to end this
on a high note
all right if we can't
buy
appliances
we can at least buy things to help us
out throwing a dope party such as
decorations plants
you know how fresh this party's gonna be
with this tree by the tv it's a party
now oh yeah
check check it out there's gonna be this
weird mask on the wall which is not at
all sinister
okay so we have looking over you okay so
we have like seven minutes left on the
stream so what what are we gonna try to
achieve here are we gonna try to call
the whole neighborhood over and have
them all die at a house fire that would
be awesome but we can't build we can't
we can't cook can't cook man what about
listen i want people to die in a fire as
much as you do
the fireplace
thing into a terrible place okay yeah
fireplace no i think that's oh is that
that's in miscellaneous feel that might
be a dlc
just put like a million light bulbs in
here
what's that spoon and fork
oh i see what you're doing yeah okay
you're sorting by room right so you have
to hit that yeah go to kitchen
none of those is kitchen
which i don't even know how i'm sorting
by room i just scroll over these little
icons at the bottom easier yeah it's
miscellaneous
no no like scroll a little bit i'm just
scrolling there appliances oh yeah
that's jacked
jacked up
oh wait go back yeah go back there then
one of these
the bottom i think the the pots and pans
kitchen
what is this what is the dining room
dining room ah
there you go that's stupid as hell
and by that i mean me
sorry guys all right we got a fridge now
nice tub of the lion fridge let's create
an unsafe situation hey call everybody
over first
wendy on the telephone get friend's over
house party
pizza delivery guy we're not gonna cook
if there's a pizza
i feel like that is that true you're
gonna want to cook anyway all right now
you need to call
i bet mario's not around to burn the
house down he was really good at that
you know he's quite good he's got a lot
of strength oh yeah let's get dina over
here let's get goopy guilty
people you've met that's too bad that's
fine
we can have a nice little shindig with
dina and
yes they're all invited
break out the refreshments
yup already did this call him again be
real needy
she's worried about having a bad
conversation with goopy she wants to be
best friends with her dad bowser
all right i've gotta answer the door
where is bowser
get down here
run
put a little pep in your step vows
let them all in bowser
yeah
talk to lauren
get that pizza to the hizza
bring it inside first you animal
yeah
these koopas
all right goopy
yeah you're gonna say hi to all of them
or else they won't come in
you got a what yeah you gotta greet them
all or else they won't come in oh
read everyone
with your mouth full of pizza you slob
oh bowser stop eating
you don't deserve to eat put that pizza
on the ground put that eaten pizza on
the table and go greet your guests
wendy i want you to clean up this pizza
i need to get it out of here
i need to create a situation
in which people need
all right everyone get in all right i
think they're all yep no goopy is still
wandering the yard like some sort of
vagrant back door
me take the back door
hoopy all right i think it's time to
start yep i took this i took the garbage
out
we're gonna have to create some uh let's
get to get some comfortable furniture in
here
one of these are super flammable
yep
this is the no fail burn your house down
tactic patented
uh
yeah what do we do also hanging plants
above the stove
we did some some curtains
yep that's that's a really well supposed
get rid of the fire alarm oh nuts how do
i get rid of things
i think control click
oh no you're holding on to that thing
move that thing first
no there's more fire alarms i remember i
put one over bowser's bed
no too much safety
it can't be a cool party with all this
come on stupid safety
okay i'm not gonna be able to wait okay
all right all right all right don't
worry guys this party's not gonna be a
snoozer for long
it's gonna heat up although they i mean
they had a bite of pizza is that gonna
sustain them who knows
this look
if you make them recliners recliners
everywhere
couches sure
make it real awkward in here it's a
really comfortable in this house
this guy could leave though i don't want
that to happen
here we go
and
back door yeah yeah
back door recliner
and
just get rid of the back door
you know you know how we can't do
construction things
bam oh it happened
all right this place is ready to rock
all right so get a job in the slacker
career of course she does
i want you to have dinner
should i make some mac and cheese
all right wendy just figure it out wendy
this is your own oh no she can't get to
the house
all right
fine no don't sit in that chair oh she's
not oh she's already sitting in the
chair oh that's fine then go oh yeah now
you can get oh yeah you just had to
climb over a cherry a little lazy
koopaling
all right wait i need those curtains
back
i feel like those were an intricate part
of my uh flammable
plan victory shot i forgot where they
are
decoration
all right oh you got a friend there
yep we're gonna have some more
real bad situations erupt here shortly
and just so that we
combo this a little better i think we
need a big couch
right here
yeah
all right
oh wendy
wendy make some food and be terrible at
it
goopy is afraid of goats oh [ __ ] she
can't get to the counter and get rid of
that one couch she needs to counter that
she's gonna go to the table she'll live
on the table
why did you just put out milk what is
that what are you serving to your guests
the milk is for the mac and cheese all
right you can't get to this
do the tv dinner because she doesn't
have to prepare that she can just stick
that at this thing
oh okay
he's mad
cancel that
yeah yeah don't prepare that
stop that
what are you yelling from back there now
bowser's gonna do it
rugs
you hearing us boxers got us bowser's
got us bowser is gonna take care of
business
yeah just go ahead and
walk away from that bowser
run over here
just forget about it
no just forget about it run over here no
it worked
bowser is a way better cook than mario
all right there we go
these guys really know how to throw a
party
lesson learned
they're both just like eating food by
themselves while dina talks to goopy
party stinks
there's not even anyone dying in the
fire
ugh
worst
why do these people ever respond to the
evites at the koopa house
look at how many mac and cheeses there
are out there look she's so mad she's so
hungry i'm making her just take food out
and she's not able to eat it she can't
prepare it because there's no doubt
goopy and dina are in the bathroom
together everything is gone not
according to plan here no one is dying
in a fire
goopy and dina are making out in the
bathroom
everyone
oh
okay now speed up time just make it
happen faster
wait don't serve mac and cheese
it worked again
oh the party's almost over let's just
take this party to its inevitable
conclusion of there you go
not bad that's a party
but they can't get out okay let's just
keep this running let's keep running
let's see how long they survive without
get rid of the fridge
all right fridge
so sorry
here we go let's see how long let's see
how long they survive real quick
and uh the party ended around tuesday
midday
get rid of the toilet get rid of the
toilet none of the guests could leave
the school bus will arrive
there were no sources of water
you can't delete an object you gotta
let's go yeah there you go
separate piece
as the days wore on
goopy and dina began to wonder
what sort of horrible situation had they
found themselves in
this few dishes few tv dinners and macs
and cheese they're like all over the
place ended up rawing as the guests
tried to sustain themselves throughout
the long day of tuesday fighting broke
out wendy passed out for a little while
she
was she comatose or was she just cranky
no one knew
and bowser is down also uh where did
bowser bowser power passing out the last
one standing was goopy
goopy turned into a zombie who just
watched oh
they got back up oh that's gross he just
pooped and pissed himself oh goopy deena
lying in a puddle of her own vomit what
she threw up nobody knows must have been
something she ate before the party oh
gosh this is just turning into a
snake
goopy assumes the fetal position and
died goopy is dead oh my god look at all
the goopy is the first to go
bowser
goopy died there's earn who's gonna be
next we're taking bets now bowser's down
to the fetal position it's not looking
looking for bowser bouncing down wendy's
down oh the finale dina the last woman
standing
here
in the house of horrors
but even she too
will soon perish
even though death stopped to watch tv
did he really yeah did you see that he
sat down on the couch to watch tv
oh
and finally
inevitably
there are no actions available
thanks for joining us here on a dark
episode of the sean method uh pretty
dark that was pretty dark but the sims 2
you know it's uh it allows us to do this
kind of cathartically so that we don't
have to burn tv dinners and burn down
our own homes right benito indeed i
won't have to go to chris's house and
burn his house down now thank goodness
uh
thank you folks for watching thank you
for helping us celebrate ongoing video
game history month here on gamespot with
this 10 year old classic uh we've got 10
years old that's crazy we've got a bunch
more stuff going up on the site this
week that's going to make you say
blank blank years old that's crazy
possibly i'm so old uh i can't believe
it all common things um but so keep an
eye out for that and join us in two
hours for the lobby we're gonna have a
bunch of fun here including greg
cassaven coming by to play transistor
and an old classic game that he has a
fondness for so join us then thanks for
watching see you later bye
you